gray skies and rain weren't enough to
dampen the spirits of those in sydney
keen to embrace what's been described as
freedom day
it's finally good to get out and just to
be a bit free see my friends and family
again
you know the little things go get a
coffee breakfast it's very good yeah
yeah great to be back out and doing some
work and getting back into community
being stuck at home with kids and work
and housework so it's just amazing to
have the opportunity now to get out go
to pub get my hair cut
excellent
on monday sydney lifted its lockdown
after four months of stay-at-home rules
gymnasiums restaurants beauticians pubs
and hairdressers reopened to fully
vaccinated residents
covered rules had banned household
visits and traveled beyond a
five-kilometer zone separating many
families those restrictions were also
removed with the state's premier
declaring australians need to learn to
live with the coronavirus and reopen the
economy it's been a very difficult time
for our state and as i said the
this issue is not over there's a long
journey
in front of our state there will be
challenges that come our way
but we have to open up and and we have
to get people back into work
more than 70 percent of people in new
south wales over 16 years of age have
now been vaccinated once the target of
80 is reached more regulations will be
eased
restrictions are still in place across
other parts of australia here in
queensland the state is trialing home
quarantine but the number of cases here
has been minimal in states like victoria
the lockdown continues with a number of
infections continuing to rise and
whether you're in a state like new south
wales that is opening up today a state
like victoria that soon will be or over
in the west or up in queensland where
the impact of covert has not been the
same but still we need those vaccines to
ensure that when covert inevitably comes
that in those states you'll be able to
continue on as you have the prime
minister has vowed to lift the caps on
international flights for those stranded
australians wanting to return home with
airlines set to return to the air within
weeks
sarah clark al jazeera queensland
australia